you're the expert can you break down how
would you describe grooming oh
absolutely first
the pedophiles want a kid who's
sexualized who will participate and
choose to have sex with them that's what
they want but you got to get a kid's
sexualized first you know what porn does
to an adult brain I mean I've talked to
porn addicts an adult brain it changes
the chemistry of the brain it actually
creates a damage of the brain kids whose
brains are just like crystallizing still
they're little sponges so you give you
give a third grader this and they're
giving third graders this stuff and then
you expose them to tick tock and let
them have the I mean you these kids by
the time they're 13 they're sex robots
they all they know they're teaching kids
to masturbate too in some schools yes
that's part of it go to your official
corner and touch yourself while you look
at this so these kids are already
sexualized to the point where and again
pedophiles are salivating like hey
they're doing our job for us these
groups the the the the leftists out
there they're doing our job yeah for us
they're laughing They're laughing right
now
they are doing the job for us why not
they are doing the job
the the groups are one and the same I
mean you're right the the I I made this
argument there was um
I can't remember exactly what the story
was but I I was critical of literal
grooming in fact let's go back to uh pre
Elon Musk Twitter
there was an image of adult men showing
graphic adult images to children and I
said this is grooming I got suspended
they deleted the tweet and they they
said you can't post this kind of stuff
and I'm like
I can't call out the abuse they said it
was offensive it was hate speech wow so
well I criticize a story and I get these
leftist Publications
attacking me for it my response was if
my position is that child abusers are
bad and you rush to their defense and
attack me over it my only assumption is
you're a child abuser or you are in
support of child abuse both are wrong
yeah they get so angry about it but I'm
like there's no legitimate reason
to defend what they're doing in these
schools and for the same reason no
legitimate reason to attack sound of
Freedom so that's the same motive and
these guys also every one of the most of
these Publications by the way you're
going to find they're also promoting
this stop calling them pedophiles that's
mean call them minor attracted persons
and add them to the lgbtq I will
absolutely not yeah it works do you
think that I've heard yesterday I think
you mentioned the average age of a child
that sees pornography on the Internet is
seven years old
by some statistics and also five
thousand percent increase in child
trafficking are they somehow related is
this absolutely The Grooming absolutely
because they want willing victims they
want willing victims let me let me ask
you something about we've been talking
about this uh for the past couple weeks
if someone goes out in the public
holding up a graphic image of adults in
engaging in adult activities that person
gets arrested no question cop comes and
arrest them
the internet is a publicly accessible
space in much the same way
but for some reason we have not enforced
laws it's preventing people from posting
obscene lewd lascivious images in places
children have access to
why what's the difference now I know
there's a lot of Libertarians who are
like oh you're talking dangerous talk
Tim we gotta have freedom here and I'm
like we don't have the freedom to go and
put up take it take an advertising truck
with a TV on it park at the middle of
Times Square and play porn you can't do
that no they will come and tell that
vehicle to arrest you on the spot so how
is it that you can go on a social media
platform children use
and do the exact same thing
that's that's a question I have perhaps
I don't have the moral Authority or the
understanding to say what we should or
shouldn't do I lean towards maybe we
should make that we should enforce it as
illegal as it should be I'm wondering if
you would agree or what your thoughts
would be on that I mean I I do it it's
this weird double standard I'd say the
same thing if you see what kids are
doing if you're gonna talk about this
tomorrow on your show but what adults
are doing to kids in these in these
forms and these parades they're doing or
the or the you know the drag queen shows
I mean you've seen the videos they're
exposing themselves if that same person
walked to a school playground did that
same thing they'd be arrested but again
what's the they're still kids they're
kids in both places
um and here we are again and and there
are states I think uh I think Tennessee
who are trying to do crate laws that
protect kids from that material that you
can't just post whatever there's there's
certain barriers there's there's ID
requirements that have to be verified
for a kid to get through a certain you
know a wall in in the internet I'm I'm I
think that's important to protect kids
yeah one thing
um I want to mention here you were sort
of talking about genderqueer and a lot
of this perverse literature that they're
putting into the school system one thing
that a lot of people aren't aware of is
that this isn't something on the fringes
and even what you were talking about
with respect to the pedophile who's
depicted at the beginning of sound of
Freedom who has written about how he
thinks these are natural impulses in
society's puritanical this person
unfortunately is part of a movement
which is much broader and more
mainstream Than People realize Alfred
Kinsey Wardell Pomeroy all the premier
sex researchers who we are told to look
to as experts and Pioneers said similar
things Kinsey wrote in his book sexual
behavior in the human female that the
reason a girl is traumatized when she's
abused when she's underage is because
the parents made a big deal out of it
and not because of what actually
happened this is in his published work
this is the person who's credited as
being the first person to scientifically
study sex his first book sexual behavior
in the human male was published in 1948
and sold several hundred thousand copy
this is a textbook people were reading
it and there was a table infamously
titled table 34 that includes data
tables which only could have been
collected through the abuse of children
I'm not going to graphically explain
what those data tables purport to
measure but it's hundreds and hundreds
of boys under the age of 15 who had to
have been raped for him to get that
information this is mainstream it's
public knowledge his co-author author
Wardell Pomeroy was in Time magazine in
the 1980s saying out loud that he thinks
incest between adults and children can
be in his words beneficial this is not
even hiding under the rug there's an
interview on the Phil Donahue show with
people from the Kinsey Institute in
Judith reason and they're defending all
of this saying that it was okay so these
aren't Fringe weirdos here and there
this stuff is way more mainstream Than
People realize it is it's just taking
this long but he's the father by the way
not only of our sex modern sex education
programs like this stuff he's also the
father of the pedophile movement yeah it
all during from the same sick you know
backwards falsehoods yeah so thank you
for that I mean you you clearly know
yourself
you're talking about this uh this
pedophile at the beginning of the film
and also a real guy that you studied who
made that claim that all men have these
predilections or whatever and you thinks
everyone steals it's it's exactly like
it's the projection it's the world must
be the way I see it everyone must see
the world the way I do there's no other
explanation certainly
you know I'll put it this way I don't
think I was ever accused these people of
being smart something's clearly wrong
with them but
it's like my dude every country on the
planet is it to varying degrees wants to
stop you
right the United States is actively in
the process of trying to stop you
clearly the world thinks what you are
doing is wrong to believe otherwise is
insanity these people but I said you
know I I don't know I wouldn't accuse
people of being smart even even Epstein
was not smart enough right right I gotta
know man like after having experienced
the last 20 years and making the movie
and everything how do you do you have
kids too if you I don't know if you want
to talk about it or not or but like how
do you educate your children about
sexuality now do they need to be
educated younger do they just need the
words to understand the body parts so
that if something they see something
they can tell you
um I mean I the idea of like saying no
go away I just don't I don't know that
that can ever work but let me let me
elaborate a little bit on that is you
know if there's a kid who doesn't
understand what's happening to them and
they can't articulate it how do you
navigate that that problem right so I I
my wife's in charge of that I try to
support but what she does and this this
requires actual parenting to do this you
have to know your kids intuitively and
and moms have a gift
um my wife certainly does the gifts I
wish I had but I don't and so it's
interesting each of my kids have the
conversation at a different age some
it's seven some it's ten some wasn't
they weren't ready until they're 12 or
13. my wife literally prays over when
it's time to say what and what to say
and what details to give also listen to
your kids ask questions so you've got to
give them the basics a certain point
right like you said they have to have
the vocabulary to be able to understand
where dangers come in but the kids will
ask and and satisfy their curiosity
otherwise the playground will and you
don't want the playground to satisfy
their curiosity so Catherine listens
okay you're going somewhere you have a
sit down I will be the one that gives
you the answer before somebody else does
so did you give them internet access
when they were younger it's the same uh
same process that some of my kids were
ready at 10 to begin monitored some not
till they're 13. it depends on for you
it depends each gets customized you know
it's got to be monitored because I want
people I don't know where this this
culture came from this idea of like the
kid can go online have fun you're
basically saying you are giving your kid
a private jet to go anywhere in the
world and see whatever they want clearly
you would never allow that you're not
going to let your kid go down to the you
know you can't you you can't go north of
this street you can't go four blocks out
we tell our kids you know when I'm
growing up it's like don't go past this
street I'll go past the street and we'd
listen for the most part come home when
the lights come on there were
limitations on how far we could go if
you went too far and you got lost you
got kidnapped something bad happened to
you how your parents gonna find out the
internet may not be the exact same thing
in terms of physical space but you can
access literally anything
that's ridiculous to allow a kid to do
it every imagine if you were like you're
allowed to go wherever you want son even
the adult bookstore down the street go
go like no way and not only that they
wouldn't let you in it would be it's
illegal but the internet is different
they let kids do whatever they want they
don't think about it parents really need
to understand
it's not just quote unquote the Internet
it's unrestrained access to some of the
worst and the best things Humanity has
created not every kid is ready for all
that yeah I mean kids I I would say
there's a large quantity of things on
the internet no one could handle seeing
yeah let alone children with one click
yeah well there's there's videos of
murder yeah they're they're I remember
back in the day there was a viral video
of three guys murdering someone that was
going around and if you were just some
kid and your parents gave you a phone or
a computer you saw a graphic and brutal
murder take place that the children
should not be watching that stuff well
you made this point about the fact that
you wouldn't be allowed in an adult
bookstore if you were just walking down
the street or a place that sells
pornography I shouldn't use and that's
the missiles and not only that but
PornHub band access in the state of Utah
because Utah passed a law saying we need
to have stricter methods of verifying
people's ages so that kids don't end up
viewing porn on this website that made
PornHub very upset so not only is it the
case that kids are allowed into these
like digital establishments the
companies actually throw a fit when they
aren't
um and I'll also mention this
my dad made this point when I was a kid
and he was referring to television I
think it's even more pressing with the
internet today but he said this is the
first time in human history where
parents allow complete strangers into
their home to teach their children and
now uh it's it's two-way you know your
kid has an exchange with them the uh the
Trevor Project posted this interface
that they were advertising to talk to uh
somebody about your sexual identity and
if you hit the escape button three times
it deletes all of your browser history
and they were advertising that wow
they're advertising that so if an adult
walks in the room hit Escape three times
all of it's cleared now what would you
say about an adult who goes to a kid
tries to talk to him about sex and says
don't tell your parents horrifying it's
like textbook absolutely it's horrifying
it's grooming and it's part of again the
pedophile movement they've been saying
it for years get separate kids from the
parents thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time